ala vient d'avoir 85 ans sa fille marine
a installé au royaume uni depuis 24 ans
est venu pour célébrer son anniversaire
avec ses soeurs en dépit de la guerre
oui c'était important pour moi c'était
une vraie fête
marina cadre de l'institut ukrainien de
londres est très attaché à son pays
d'origine elle a grandi ici haïr pin et
y revient au moins une fois par an
ma mère devient fragile c'était d'autant
plus important si on se retrouve que
malgré la guerre d'être ensemble se
sentir en panique ça nous donne la force
et le sentiment que nous allons
surmonter la situation
quelques heures avant son retour à
londres marina a tenu à montrer à ses
deux fils le pont par lequel ses proches
ont fui l'avancée russe en mars un pont
devenu symbole de la résistance
ukrainienne
j'avais 20 ans quand l'ukraine est
redevenue indépendante
j'en ai 51 aujourd'hui
et j'ai vécu tout ça comme des millions
d'ukrainiens c'est une histoire qui
détermine notre vie le fait que
l'ukraine devienne un pays vraiment
indépendant vraiment européens et ils en
payent le prix fort
cette histoire de l'émancipation face à
la russie marina souhaite la transmettre
à ses enfants qui ont grandi à des
milliers de kilomètres
j'avais assez peur de marché sur une
mine
je fais toujours attention et où je mets
mes pieds
c'est surréaliste
depuis notre naissance on vit à londres
mais je sent clairement que ma famille
vite ici que c'est clairement mon pays
je voulais qu'ils entrent dans leur
mémoire ce moment déterminant de notre
histoire
depuis la capitale britannique marina va
continuer à mobiliser pour une crème
qu'elle veut libre et européenne